[Musique]
moi c'est Arnaud Bazin moi la grandi à
Saint-Pierre moi les musiciens
aujourd'hui et après des études de mal
presque classique avec un bac économique
Mo la lance à Mo dans l'animation auprès
des enfants au départ et puis ensuite
malorient à moins en parallèle m'allait
dire à cette professionnalisation de la
musique pour être aujourd'hui professeur
de musique en
collège VO a comencer à collecter en
fait en travail en partenariat avec mon
président d'association qui s'appelle
Antoine Tichon dit DJ Console nous l'
créé une association qui appelle créol
art et depuis bientôt 10 ans B nous
milite autour de du patrimoine musical
et le Conseil départemental aide à nous
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises pour
mettre en place des expositions aux
Archiv autour des partitions parce que
nous connais que la plus vieille
partition que nous nous l' retrouvé elle
date de 1777 donc la musique rignonnaise
l' écrit au moins depuis cette cette
date là et puis il a enchaîné avec une
une exposition autour des disques vinyes
parce qu'un des plus grosses collections
manena c'est une collection de disques
vinyes de la Réunion Maurice Madagascar
les schelles sur une période qui va on
vaer dire de 1900 à nos
jours et en même temps moi les
professeurs rel nationale au niveau de
l'iconoèque c'estàd que il fait un petit
peu le lien entre les professeurs de
collège et cette structure qui
[Musique]
appelle